hallo herzlich willkommen zur sallys
welt ich möchte heute einen leckeren
streuselkuchen machen
ursprünglich wollte ich eigentlich einen
aprikosen mond streuselkuchen machen
aber ich habe keine aprikosen bekommt
deswegen gibt es heute einen 40 mond
streuselkuchen und ich werde jetzt
diesem ohne füllung selber machen
die gibt es ja auch schon fertig
abgepackt im supermarkt diesem montag
mischung und ich zeige euch jetzt ganz
einfach wie die funktioniert deswegen
seht ihr jetzt auch erstmal nur vier
zutaten denn ich möchte erst die mond
film herstellen und seid euch dann
später einfach noch die restlichen
zutaten also für die mol füllung
brauchen wir 125 gramm blauen 80
milliliter milch 40 gramm zucker und 25
gramm butter und jetzt muss ich zuerst
in unser kleiner in so einem normalen
mixa funktioniert es nicht deswegen
nehme ich den ab und benutze dafür die
gewürze
da fühle ich jetzt kurz den mund hinein
ich mache es jetzt auf zwei portionen
damit nicht zuviel mohn auf einmal ist
jetzt einfach bei höchster stufe
den ersten teil fühle ich jetzt schon
mal um und mal noch die zweite hälfte
jetzt muss ich den mond noch mit den
restlichen zutaten vermischen und
aufkochen
jetzt könnt ihr das entweder ganz
traditionell auf dem herd machen im talk
bei niedriger stufe ich mach das jetzt
einfach kurz in der kenwood weil es für
mich einfacher ist ich kann da die
temperatur einstellen ich stelle es
jetzt gleich auf 90 grad
aber wenn ihr es auf dem herd macht
einfach auf mittlerer stufe und dann
eben etwas früheren jetzt gebe ich die
zutaten hier rein
dann setze ich hier noch das frühe
element drauf und lass' uns erst mal
kurz durch rühren und jetzt gebe ich da
die temperatur drauf ich stelle jetzt
auf 90 grad und dann lasse ich das so
etwa dreieinhalb minuten verrühren und
wenn ihr das wie gesagt auf im topf
macht macht er das auch so drei bis vier
minuten bei niedriger stufe
aus
nach dem erhitzen erhalten so eine
wunderschöne mohn füllung und die könnt
ihr übrigens auch benutzen um zum
beispiel sonne mond zu machen also wenn
er zum beispiel keine lust darauf machen
will sondern muss ob könnte diese
füllung benutzen
und ich lasse jetzt aber noch ein
bisschen abkühlen die kann noch ein
bisschen quellen
deswegen lege viel zur seite und kann
jetzt schon mal den teig zubereiten und
zeigt euch da kurz die zutaten
ich habe hier etwas quark milch eigelb
etwas zucker eine prise salz mehl und
backpulver und jetzt gebt ihr zuerst die
flüssigen und feuchten zutaten in eine
rührschüssel könnte jetzt auch mit dem
handrührgerät zum beispiel machen also
zuerst quark
dann auch mit rein
dann auch milch eingriffe und ich gebe
jetzt auch schon mal den zucker und die
prise salz mit dazu und verrührt ist
jetzt einmal kurz
und wenn sich die zutaten verbunden
haben
wer möchte ich jetzt hier backpulver und
mehl und fügt es eben auch noch dazu
und dann wird es ein schöner gerta teig
ich gebe es zuerst mal einen teil dazu
mich kurz durch und dann auf den rest
und dann entsteht eigentlich nicht an
den fingern klebt und damit kleide ich
jetzt meine backform aus und zwar habe
ich jetzt hier schon mal bekamen
gerichtet den auf 26 cm eingestellt und
mit backpapier eingeschlagen und jetzt
soll ich den teig etwas größer aus so
etwa auf 30 cm und kann es dann schön
damit belegen
jetzt einfach hier in die backform rhein
und die ränder schön hochziehen hab da
so eine zwei zentimeter hohen rand
den teig könnte es dann einfach kann man
so kurz an der seite stehen lassen ich
werde zumal die streusel vorbereiten und
dafür brauche ich die zutaten und 250
gramm mehl 50 gramm zucker und 100 gramm
weiche butter und ich nehme dafür auch
so 1 2 esslöffel von diesem von dieser
montag mischung und später für die
füllung brauche ich auch noch 14 500
gramm oder aprikosen und die habe ich
jetzt auch schon mal bereit gestellt
wird gibt ihr die zutaten für die
streusel hier nochmal in die schüssel da
nehme ich jetzt auch einfach die
dreckige schüssel also die sind ich
denke ich aber da war der teig drin
ihr braucht keine frische schlüssel dann
der zucker mit rein
die butter
und sobald sich das dann alles vermischt
hat gebe ich noch ein bisschen von dem
montag getrennt
die streusel masse fühle ich jetzt und
stellt sie kurz in den kühlschrank und
dann gehe ich jetzt gleich kochendes
wasser hier über die pfirsiche damit ich
sie gleich heute kann und wer dann noch
die letzten zu taten bereit stellen und
zwar das sind die zutaten für die
füllung da kennt bekommt nämlich noch so
ne wie seh masse mit rein und dann kann
man es gleich geschafft durch den kuchen
zusammen
die presse habe ich jetzt heiß
übergossen damit ich sie gleich mehrfach
häuten kann
und hier stehen jetzt auch schon die
zutaten für die füllung und zwar habe
ich hier zwei weise das sind die zwei
von den gelben die im teig benutzt habt
dann eine prise salz 40 g zucker und
einen esslöffel zitronensaft und jetzt
gibt dir zuerst dass die anreise hier in
der schüssel
das muss jetzt eine saubere und fettfrei
erschlossen sein sonst werden sie
nämlich nicht steif da kommt etwas salz
mit rein und dann ruhig das jetzt auf
höchster stufe
so etwa zehn sekunden und gibt dann nach
und nach dem zucker mit rhein und ruhr
so lange bis es eben eine richtig schöne
feste steife bis die masse ist
jetzt ist die schneemasse schön fest
zieht man auch hier also richtig tolle
schnee und jetzt habe ich hier die
montag mischung ein
ich sag schon backmischung montag
füllung zwar keine backen chance
und es werde zu den untergehoben
jetzt kommt diese füllung direkt auf den
kuchenteig
dann streicht ich sie schön glatt
beruf
und jetzt muss ich nur noch die vier
sicherheiten und kann sie dann drauf
legen natürlich vorher halbieren
auf
und jetzt schneide ich die 40 stücke
noch in schöne spalten und falls ihr
euch den vorgang mit dem schälen mit dem
kleinen scheinen ersparen wollten wir
einfach fair sicher aus der dose oder
wie gesagt ab kursen da geht es
einfacher weil die vor allem wenn sie
ganz reif sind ganz weich sind
und jetzt könnt ihr die 40 stücke schön
auf dieser module und platzieren
entweder rein stecken oder drauflegen so
wird es gern haben möchte
ich mache das jetzt von außen nach innen
und jetzt fehlen nur noch die streusel
die verteile ich jetzt einfach grob
drüber ich habe übrigens vergessen -im
esslöffel zitronensaft zur mohn füllung
wir dazu zu geben
auf jeden fall kölner denen noch mit
rein geben darunter heben
und jetzt kann der kuchen gebacken
werden und zwar im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 175 grad
ich schätze er brauchte ungefähr 35
minuten
ihr könnt auf jeden fall dann auf die
farbe schauen also wenn der teig außen
dieser helle teig so ein bisschen farbe
bekommt und die streusel dann durch sind
dann ist er fertig und dann zeige ich
ihn euch so steht jetzt der fertige
kuchen aus ich habe jetzt bereits auf
eine tortenplatte gesetz und bestäuben
ist noch mit süßem schnee was ist etwas
was ich finde es immer so lustig
bestäuben streuen gestalten sagte
gestreute straßen schnee beim bestäuben
wie man an bienen
und darfst du gleich ein stückchen
probieren
also ich mag ja mohnkuchen so gerne ich
mag man allgemein sehr und ich mag auch
mond sehr gerne deswegen ist das
eigentlich der perfekte kuchen für mich
ich weiß nicht wie du so mond stehst
ich habe jetzt gar nicht die das ist ja
jetzt der gemahlin wie toll das aussehen
also ich mag meinen nicht immer muss ich
ehrlich sagen also unten dieser teig
dieser quarkteig dann die pfirsiche der
mond füllung mit dem leckeren knusprigen
sträußen also in der dns schmeckt weiß
ja auch nicht ich will ehrlich du darfst
immer ehrlich mein größter kritiker
machen klecks sahne
du bist auch die besten
die bilder wieder irgendwas und es
riecht hat richtig lecker nach monaco
ich finde es gibt nichts besseres als
montag
ich probiere jetzt nicht weil danach
habe ich bestimmt von die schwarzen
szene
deswegen lasse ich sitze ich probier
gleich wenn die kamera aus ist
vor allem wird er auch sehr feucht sein
mein innen drin haben wir diese weiß
masse ist kein trockener kuchen
obwohl es eigentlich so im prinzip ein
trockner kuchen ist weil er keine
fruchtige sahne creme füllung oder so
hat und ich denke man kann auch ganz gut
einfrieren und dann eben bei bedarf
wieder auftauen
ich habe zwar mit drin da ist kein
marzipan das wäre so eine idee ich finde
so schmeckt lecker aber wenn man mal
machen müssten willst dann geh ich dir
noch eine neuere mohnkuchen mitzufahren
und vielleicht anderen früchten mache
ich auf jeden fall gibt's das rezept
nachzulesen auf see ließen das blog de
de moura schmeckt er vertritt den kuchen
und ich las mit den jetzt auch gleich
schmecken zu einer tasse tee und freue
mich jetzt nicht immer wieder
einschaltet und bisschen uns ein ganz
bald
bis dahin tschüss